hey guys how's it going I just wanted to  tell you that I'm going to comic-con so  I'm preparing videos and I'll be busy  all day so unfortunately if I can't get  two videos per day then you're not  enough time I'm gonna go see my brother  Lorna of the webcomic T kinds well we're  gonna have a lot of fun  also I'm gonna be debuting on press card  play down there also I found my glasses  so I want you to reach debate in the  comments below  whether or not I've ever missed without  me thanks so much for watching game  builders jumbled in this day but this is  very important Tom you're setting your  finger down business go global so if you  wanted to go over them or anyone know go  please tell me or else I'm not gonna be  able to survive  okay bye bye